[Music]
hi troy how are you
i'm doing great thanks for asking and
thanks dave and thanks rachel for taking
my call this afternoon sure how can we
help
you know my wife and i have been big
fans and we've followed a lot of your
teachings and precepts over the years
and it's allowed us to
come to a place of having no debt other
than a little bit left over on a uh
on a primary mortgage
we'd like to move out of sacramento
and i'm my question directly is
if we paid off our home would be we
would be debt free and it'd be great and
then we would be freed up to invest more
and more into either retirements or
other
investment opportunities
my question is do you ever consider
a larger mortgage like buying a more
expensive home in a more expensive area
as your primary residence
as an investment vehicle rather than
using the money and investing in say the
stock market
well the problem with that is that
you're violating the rule of
diversification
because then you've got so much tied up
in one asset
so let me give you an example as we're
studying the uh 10 000 millionaires in
the ramsey study of millionaires
when we would run across one and they
were very rare but occasionally we would
run across one that was a millionaire
maybe their net worth is a million two
but their paid for home is a million one
well they're legitimately a millionaire
i mean their net worth is over a million
dollars but that's a little scary
because they're not diversified and that
asset does not create an income for them
at retirement
right it creates a place for them to
live and so they could live in a six
hundred thousand dollar paid for house
and have six hundred thousand dollars
with a million two in other words
invested creating income
and so the
while the home is an asset it's not an
income producing asset
right
so you know in our situation our
retirement 401k is just shy of a million
dollars you know that our daughter's
colleges um you know we've saved and we
have that essentially taken care of with
scholarships that they've received you
know we've got the emergency fund put in
place we've got cash in the bank
the current home value that we have is
about 575 and we owe about 170 000 on it
and uh
and so we you know we feel like we've
got a good base we could continue doing
that pay off the house and so what price
range home would you be in with your
investment concept that you're pitching
well it's just it's right around a
million dollars
and so you know a 30 year old so you're
currently at one six one seven net worth
right
um right in there and you'd have a
million of it in your home
uh if we went down that road yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's a little high that's a
little high that makes me a little
nervous it's not it's not it's not over
in the stupid column it's just the
nervous approaching stupid column
okay i'm joking around with you you guys
are brilliant you're millionaires way to
go congratulations i'm so proud of you
you've done a lot of things right so all
we're doing is just discussing the fact
that um you're going to have uh what uh
60
of your net worth tied up in non-income
producing assets i'll give you another
example right now i'll give you another
example of that okay i've got a 250 acre
farm
that is that does absolutely nothing
except hold the earth together and as a
place for me to shoot guns and drive
four-wheelers it does not create any
income
it's worth millions of dollars okay
but it does not create any income if
that was the larger portion of my total
net worth
that would be unwise
because it really is a receptacle for
bullets and four-wheelers that's really
all it does it doesn't create anything
for me to live off of and so even though
it's a wonderful investment because it's
going it's in a it's in a prime location
it's it's in one of the fastest growing
counties in the nation you know it's
it's wonderful ground but as you know
someday when some ramsey sells it it
won't be while i'm alive but while some
ramsey sells it they will do very well
on it but it's not an income producer so
that's the whole that's the whole
discussion and you guys just got to
balance that out in your minds and go
okay and what is our income and how much
can we add to the 700 000 of income
producing assets if we do this so that
it's less and less and less and less out
of balance it starts to bother me
what percentage because like you said 60
there but what's the yeah i mean when
you get north of 50 it's start to be
scary i mean yeah you got a million two
and a half of it's in a house that's not
too bad as long as you're adding to your
investments right yeah um but i i'm but
again it would change excuse the
percentages would skew as you go way up
too so let's say you had a 20 million
dollar net worth well i wouldn't want
you to be anywhere near that in your
personal residence
sure yeah you know maybe maybe uh 1 20th
5 would be a million dollar house yeah
or a 2 million dollar house would be 10
with a 20 million net worth but you
shouldn't be sitting around a 10 million
dollar house with a 20 that would be
ridiculous yeah you know
you can do it but i just don't think
it'd be wise yes and so
in my mind it would be ridiculous and
and you're in i'm just gonna go step
further because what you're saying
though it's
mostly majority because there's not an
income producing element to it it's not
that like
the house is going to be taking it like
it's not like it's a risky thing because
it's there if he dies what's his wife
going to eat on yeah
she can't eat the bushes in front of the
house right
no matter how valuable they are she got
to sell the house in order to liquidate
to get money
and i don't want her to have to do that
i wanted to be able to live comfortably
on the income producing portion of the
portfolio
that that's what that's what's running
through my head it's they're okay as
long as they're sitting there right now
if everything stays the same he keeps
creating we don't even ask what his
income is but i'm sure it's great
i mean and he's a smart guy they're
going to do fine they're they're smart
people they're there's really not a
horrible answer in this whole thing but
that
and so you know let's say let's pretend
they make 300 000 and they're gonna have
no house payment and they're gonna be in
a million so that house is pretty well
it's gonna go up in value it's
california real estate but uh but
it's not what they're dependent on in
other words they're gonna take a 150 of
that two of that 300 start throwing and
adding to that 700
in 10 years this thing will really not
be out of whack at all yeah as long as
he doesn't die as long as he doesn't
quit working as long as that income
doesn't go away and we don't complete
the plan
but if you stop early in the plan you
might have to liquidate the house that's
what that's kind of i kind i want things
to work when they don't work and when
they do work yeah or the plan to have
addressed both sides of the equation and
that's that's all i'm
wincing about when we're talking about
this but yeah and so
yeah
the
overall idea too is diversification
spread your portions to seven yes to
eight for disaster may come upon the
land
that's a biblical reference from
ecclesiastes don't put all your eggs in
one basket
some do will cause a pandemic to happen
or
go crazy when a pandemic does happen or
something and then you'll be there there
you'll be in that mess again